[Musique]
mettez-vous à genoux les mains derrière
la nuque restez où vous êtes j'y suis et
de l'est des chevaux chu à l'e3
nous sommes en guerre et cette guerre
est secrète cette unité la dernière
ligne de défense contre une force
absolument terrifiante missionné pour
tuer pour monty rossi
devait poursuivre l'opération mais
n'engagez pas le combat
ils m'ont kidnappé quand j'avais 4 ils
m'ont retenue captive ils n'ont fait
subir tatoue moi
je peux te déchets tu veux que je fasse
confiance
plusieurs sujets augmenté ont été
retrouvés morts dans le pays l'un
d'entre vous êtes en train de vous
détruire de l'intérieur
il n'y a pas de sécurité pas de contrôle
vous allez mourir
rien ne pourra vous sauver
son corps est humain il encore du sang
dans les veines il se régénère
instantané la vie ne peut pas ouvrir le
portail avant d'avoir récupérer
l'énergie de chaque sujet divatte
poursuivi rama n'y était pour rien pour
taper parfaitement n'ai aucun d'entre
eux ce ne sont pas des choses ce sont
des arbres
[Musique]
ils avaient tous les tués étaient des
couteaux sont enfin de qui parlez
[Musique]